hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane circuit Kevin Maguire and and
repair so here's a look back at the
bigger stories of the last seven days
Andrew what was your top story those
wretched judges trying to subvert the
will of the British people we know were
their game it won't work Kevin just
Madden II know it's the sovereignty of
Parliament being upheld I thought you
wanted that well a lot more on that
because that is our top story of the
week the decision by the High Court to
force to reason may to allow MP is a
vote on the triggering of article 50 the
process by which the UK will leave the
EU here's our political editor faisal
islam to ancient institutions the
judiciary and parliament one very modern
conundrum who decides to enact the
referendum verdict to leave the European
Union the answer from the High Court not
the Prime Minister blowing open the
government's brexit plans and timetable
it was a thumping legal victory for a
challenge principally brought by
financier and philanthropist Gino Miller
it's not about me or my team it's about
our United Kingdom and all our futures
it's not about how anyone voted every
one of us voted for the best country and
the best future the defendant in the
case was brexit secretary David Davis
who vowed to appeal the results the
referendum must be respected Parliament
voted by six to one if the decision to
the people no ifs or buts and that's why
we are appealing is to get on with
delivering the best deal for Britain as
the best deal for growth the best deal
for investment the best deal for jobs
that people wanted to get on with it
that's what we intend to do it's all
sets for early December in what will be
their mother of all constitutional
battles at the Supreme Court with a
final verdict in the new year Andrea
you're very exercised about this but but
isn't this democracy in action shouldn't
MPs have a say I would have I was the
Prime Minister I wouldn't appeal it I
wouldn't go to the Supreme Court or I
would table a one-line bill in in
Parliament next week a vote to say that
the government is to trigger article 50
of course old lefties like
oh I would would table amendments but
just that let Parliament do it it should
be nothing to do with unelected
unaccountable remember a document was
put through all our tours by the
government it cost nine million pounds
and it said about the referendum it said
very clearly in that document this is
your decision the government will
implement whatever that people decide
those judges weren't listening I mean
isn't that the point Kevin the people of
the UK have voted they voted very
clearly to leave EU it's up to the
government to do it why should there be
another store yeah they have and the
people have set the principle we're
leaving we're going ours a remainer
we're going out the European Union
people voted for that in a referendum
we ridiculous attacking judges this is
about the law and it's about the
sovereignty of parliament something you
were supposed to support and instead of
having Theresa May and a few advisers in
a back room deciding the timing in terms
of our departure it will be MPs in
Parliament with a public debate who will
set that timetable and the deal and what
are you afraid of why are you so
frightened of your monster seeing people
like calamity click the Lib Dem leader
with his hundred and thirteen 115 peers
in the house a lot they will disrupt
this they would do there'd be no problem
in the comments it will sell through the
Commons but the House of Lords is
unelected unaccountable and they those
lots should be careful they're not going
to because they like the Grenada know if
his law sort them and the Lord block it
she should call a general election but
is of course our top story in a busy
news week so here are five things that
you might have missed
she's a very dishonest person probably
the most dishonest person ever to run
for the office of president you know I
am sick and tired of the negative dark
divisive dangerous vision
well the email scandal returned to haunt
Hillary Clinton in a week the full final
week of presidential campaigning Donald
Trump edged ahead according to one poll
but the Democratic candidates struck
back labeling mr. Trump a bully this
time next week the race will be over and
we should know who's headed to the White
House also this week after speculation
about his future the governor of the
Bank of England Mark Carney announced
he'd be staying in the role until the
summer of 2019 he faced an awkward
moment later in the week when he was
forced to change his growth forecast and
abandoned plans to cut the interest rate
further the Pensions Regulator confirmed
it was stepping up its investigation to
former BHS boss of Phillip Green over
the high street chains collapse in a
story first reported by our city editor
mark Kleinman the regulator headed by
Leslie Titcomb said it was yet to
receive a credible and comprehensive
plan to solve the company's pension
black hole
she's obviously run out of patience with
him as the pensioners did and Parliament
did a long time ago and has now said the
legal process is working I will come up
with a sum and if that's adjudicated is
fair you're going to have to pay how
about this for a driving lesson
police in China are punishing people who
dazzle fellow road users with their
headlights and rather unusual way
they're making them sit in front of a
vehicle and stare into the full glaze of
the headlights for a minute what do you
think is that a bright idea or not and
now bra gap of the week and it was
nominated on Twitter this week by Lee
Murphy thanks for tweeting in it goes to
this awkward moment at p.m. queues well
first of all can I congratulate the
right honourable gentleman on the birth
I understand of his granddaughter and
know
sorry
that case mr. speaker can I just say
that perhaps one should never trust a
former chief wick oh that was classic
how could she done that how did she not
know I think this was on the front page
Topsy muttered who is the chief who is
the chief what he said he's the Tauri
chairman that orici muttered something
in area about Corbin put wrong but yeah
was actually the fact that the Labour MP
Connor McGann delivered his baby
daughter in the sitting room because it
no there wasn't time for the omni's to
get there it's all over the news yeah
she that is she that touch but it wasn't
that she just doesn't actually sit down
and read and she probably thought I
don't need to read that whatever
whatever other criticisms you would have
previous Prime Minister's Cameron Brown
Blair major Thatcher they would have
known she's actually actually a rather
legend out-of-touch performer and she
gave the game away hey what do you think
I know you're a bit of a maniac fan but
but do you think she's performing and PM
cues now she's sort of gone to astride
of it I don't think I think it's not her
natural
48 actually but I think she's doing okay
because she's helped by the fact Jeremy
Corbyn is the worst leader of the
Opposition to ever go to the
despatch-box at prances crisis he is a
disaster when Tori boy says she's doing
okay you know that's called what
terrible
and don't forget send us your
nominations at likely did using the
hashtag W in are now this week
campaigners for people arrested during
the Battle of all grieve reacted angrily
after they were denied an inquiry into
one of the most notorious events of the
miners strike us guys Jared tub has this
report
the Battle of all grieve was a violent
clash in 1984 between striking miners
and the police now 32 years on a
government decision not to hold a public
inquiry was met with fury from Labour
MPs campaigners were dejected
they claimed South Yorkshire police
backed by Margaret Thatcher's government
staged the battle deliberately in 1984
all grieve was a coking works
thousands of striking miners tried to
close it with a mass picket they were
beaten back by even greater numbers of
police officers and accused of rioting
but trials collapsed over unreliable
evidence six months ago
South Yorkshire police was heavily
criticized by the Hillsborough inquests
verdict campaigners believe the football
disaster might not have happened in 1989
if all grieve had been properly
investigated announcing the decision not
to hold an inquiry the Home Secretary
disagreed in this situation in all grade
there were no miscarriages of justice
there were no convictions the campaign
group part funded by trade unions says
it will fight on South Yorkshire police
may yet hand over its files this is a
battle that is not over Kevin do you
think there should have been an inquiry
or not yes a number would led the
campaign up the garden path in meetings
where they thought she was going to
authorize and inquiry it wasn't nobody
died there were no miscarriages nobody
but nobody was charged nobody nobody
bigger people were convictions people
were people were arrested at that time
they were beaten up they were detained
by the police and the cases collapsed
duct court subsequently and people often
say why wasn't an inquiry doing the the
labor quiet it's because subsequently
officers at who are on duty have come
out said they were told to be rough with
the with a miners they've said that they
were told what to write in statements
which is fabricating evidence and we now
know South Yorkshire police without
control from the Hillsborough inquiry
and it's may not or grieve if all grieve
haven't happened and the police had been
held okay you cannot see hills but
wouldn't have happened but you can see a
pattern of behaviour here we're working
people were treated with utter contempt
and brutality by that police force 13
years of a Labour government 13 years
they did not set up an inquiry to
explain anyone figure exposing doesn't
wash
nobody
whereas the advantage would be nobody
convicted nobody sent to prison nobody
died and this remember what all grieve
is that it wasn't a battle it was one
day in a very it was one day okay call
it a one and a half days in a long
dispute about it wasn't a battle and it
was about the police trying to help
miners go to work you don't know we
always forget this because the left
don't want to report the fact that
miners were trying to go to work and
they were being stopped by unruly
pickets and these picket by the way had
never been balloted on whether they
should be on strike because Arthur
Scargill took them into a strike but
ever asking getting a mandate from the
mighty some of the colors it was it was
a disgrace they away the police behave
that day I agree but it was a disgrace
away some of the minor behave too let's
lighten the mood a quick quiz for us now
can you tell me what these are
Sharon ting brexit oh yeah mic drop and
there's more dude food you both know
they're nodding do you know it how I do
he doesn't know you know what dude food
means find out after the break
we can review with me Jane Secor I'm
joined by Kevin Maguire associate editor
of The Daily Mirror and Andrew Pierce
consultant editor of The Daily Mail
before the break we asked have you ever
eaten dude food or drop the trumpism you
knew what they were didn't you yes what
are they they're the new world Exodus
let's not go there again that the most
the most used words in the last 22 the
last 20 yes new words in the last 12
months new words at the alarming enter
dictionary and most commonly used words
for exit we will clearly be using next
year and years okay I've never heard
anybody whose expression dude food dude
food refers to food that's especially
junk food the same dat men so kind of
super-sized burgers so that's not
requiring all the time Joe Moe is sure
you've missing out so this is when you
say I'll come to the party and you sit
at home and watch the telly new crisps
and have a thoroughly lovely color that
anybody use that worked I haven't but no
no I'm not down with the kids am i
Sharon Sharon ting is people who tweet
and post on Facebook loads of pictures
of the children right yeah that's quite
sweet until it goes well you know here's
one obvious and that become a bigger
word of course if he wins no racism the
presidential hopeful has come out with
on the campaign track Louis week the
football associations of England and
Scotland clashed with the sports
governing body FIFA over where the
players could wear poppies on their kit
when the teams play on November the 11th
FIFA banned the emblem but the FA said
that they would defy that ruling here's
what Prime Minister Theresa May had to
say I think I think the stance that's
been taken by FIFA is utterly outrageous
our football players want to recognize
and respect those who have given their
lives for our safety and security I
think it is absolutely right that they
should be able to do so I think our
footballers it's for our football
associations but I think a clear message
is going from this house we want our
players to be able to wear those poppies
and I have to say to FIFA but before
they start telling us what to do they
jolly will or to salt their own house
out good walk right
should the England and Scotland players
be able to where it should be for me yes
now I wouldn't put them on in truth not
just because of FIFA although they rule
out any political religious or
commercial symbols and we'd soon
complain of the red army or the Iranian
team of the Revolutionary Guard had
symbols we own but it's not religious a
lot of people say it there is a clear
political side when it is also to raise
money for serving soldiers people who've
been involved in conflicts in Libya
Afghanistan Iraq clearly now before the
poppy police shout at me and I know we
have at this time of year the British
mutter wean here they who go around
saying you improperly dressed
I'll wear mine and the week of
Remembrance Sunday always do England of
played on Armistice Day in the past
didn't wear poppies they played on
Armistice Day Eve about 15 years who
didn't wear poppies football is latched
on to this to try and clean up its own
image that's what it's about it's not
about remembrance and sticking it on a
shirt of a player who's swearing
cheating spitting diving the crowd will
be booing is that really yeah that's not
a dignified form of respect why don't we
just stick to what we've always done you
have a minute silence before games and
their improbable behave those horns and
as a palling response of course from the
choir actually I don't have any time for
football or footballers but they are
role models they're on an international
scale good ones I don't know that often
so how nice actually that they want to
wear I got that turn day where
everywhere symbols that commemorate and
remember let's move on to your choices
of top paper stories of the week and
Andrew is stuck with you this week
questions over Keith Vaz appointment to
the new justice committee
I'm in despair about this I just don't
get it Keith has resigned as chairman at
the Home Affairs Select Committee
because of the conflict of interest so
then he thinks he's okay to be on the
Justice Select Committee
how come isn't it the same conflict of
interest of course it's there's still a
parliamentary investigation ongoing into
his conduct and the police everything
yeah who's the subject of investigation
the Tories Tory's mad madly folk TV mod
159 Tories including seven cabinet
ministers and they say yeah and they say
it's because if we begin objecting to
members of select committees other
parties might do that to you they should
have abstained if that is how they
shamed us no he is on with Tory sport
but no if you're under investigation by
the police you should not be going on
but he has this incredible brass nick
okay somebody else who also apparent has
a bit of brass neck Hazeltine michael
has a little tiny bit of a shaggy dog
story involving he appeared to suggest
he'd strangled his mother his mother's
Alsatian dog because it was threatening
his his pregnant wife Kim yeah that's
the wife trapped on this and he now just
says he subdued it as he turned the
collar and then later had it put down
but he's got a lot of blood on his hands
because we now find out he's killed 350
squirrels that were running around these
trees but it is really we thought of him
as tars and I mean he just this is the
man who tried to assassinate mrs.
Thatcher no wonder he tried to kill off
that dog I don't and this is it one of
my favorites the weekly from Gary Conway
this week you said having voted Keith
Bowers to the Justice Committee Tory MPs
or appointee Michael Heseltine judge of
next year's Westminster Dog Show now
what about the stadium under this is you
this is the cost of converting the
Olympic Stadium it's been called into
question and this was at Muskaan use
revealed this good snake yeah because
the cost has soared by 50 million pounds
that's a lot of money it will be public
money david edmonds who was in charge of
legacy post the olympic game
has quit this big questions here because
Boris Johnson was the mayor of London at
the time when the deal was done with
West Ham we have to ask Baroness Brady
who's associated with West Ham isn't she
on the board what she knows about this
and I don't think the tilde nation make
up a single penny for this because
football clubs are awash with mind if
it's fifty million more West Ham's
insist on a player that the deal when
West Ham pay two and a half million a
year and they paid fifteen million
towards a conversion cost of a stadium
that now in tool is going about be about
three quarters of a billion smacks of a
wealth fair deal between a Tory mayor at
the time Boris Johnson and West Ham's to
Tory denier in owners and Karen Brady
who's a Tory peer that this deal no
wonder Sadiq Khan Lee the new Maryland
ins called it in
it stinks it also allows you to watch
football I've seen it and they've got
huge problems with crowd control and
fans attacking others I saw it was so
money that were born with it hammer
wutface i woould Chelsea it's not a bra
I don't know about football but it's not
a football stadium it's an athletic
stadium and they should have found
another use for it frankly okay now
Kevin your final paper story this is a
Dalit admission from the singer this
week about postnatal depression and I
thought was a incredibly brave of her
because it is it still a taboo subject
in at large and she looked she loved her
ass on Angelo but she says after he was
born she kind of felt a life was over
and some women do because your body is
going through all sorts of chemical
hormonal changes you'll be
sleep-deprived and you'll be in trouble
and I just thought her talking about it
and how she was coming through it will
help a lot of other other women because
there's a lot of pressure to conform and
you say the baby's the greatest moment
in my life it's absolutely wonderful
many ways it is as you know you can say
it's a parent but it's also a huge
strain I think it's also good isn't it
under in terms of talking about
depression because so many people still
think if you're wealthy if your success
I can't have depression they think
you've got life is on a plate for you I
completely agree very courageous of her
she's fantastic saying that we may not
hear so much from her which would be
very sad but I hope you get so for it
right let's take you up your ups and
downs thanks for taking us through those
papers and Kevin we're starting with you
this week you are sending up
as Cliff Richard he was at the Pride of
Britain Awards wasn't he he was Denver a
pro Pride of Britain Awards was a very
good interview with him on Sky from the
red carpet was recorded well let's hear
a talk of it it's been difficult but
I've known all along that I had an
enormous support and so therefore it's
been a very helpful thing for me it's
difficult to explain how it felt but now
I feel fantastic and I'm here back doing
what I normally do so if it wasn't for
my face I don't know how people cope
without a faith I've lent on my faith
for two years and it's been I wouldn't
have it any other way
no no my faith stayed strong and now
it's stronger you can really see the
impact that these allegations have had
on the appointment oh yeah he looks
older and it was a two-year ordeal for
him but I see that some now I've noticed
he wears a hearing aid while he is 76
and Peter Pan Congo for us it did he
speak to you I didn't see was that but
unlike you I don't go around trust me
I've been there luckily but he's here it
might be gone might be going but he
still looks pretty good for 76 fantastic
so we're sending him up good week for
him you're sending down though Lewis
Smith there's a nurse too as now had I
had a ban from the British gymnastics
yeah two months two months an Olympic
medalist it was for for mocking Muslims
and laughing and you know in a mock
prayer which I was on a video which kid
which came out I'm not too sure about
the two months ban actually in Jimbo's
he'd already missed they it already
apologized said he spent some time in
the Muslim community did learned his
mistake did and missed all of the
celebration I think all that was quite
quite right you know Jim must say though
british gymnastics got on their high
horse and gave him that Tim with man I'm
not sure about but he was stupid but
their ban might also be related to the
fact that on an Instagram he previously
put out a photograph of the bottom of a
gymnast who was 16 at the time he didn't
he said he didn't know her age but he
put it out and invented the guy he was
stupid and he's very young but what are
they doing banning him Muslim the Muslim
faith can cope with somebody taking the
mick the
Christian faith has put up with it the
thousands of years just watch citizen
Corps so not a good not a good week for
him so we're sending Lewis Smith down
but now on to you Andrew you're sending
up this week Taylor Swift it is eye
watering so much money she's made a
million dollars nobody anywhere else
she's earned three times do you want
Madonna and now yeah and she and it's
amazing because if you played of Mia
Taylor Swift breakup I would another
clue what tell us before surely bats it
what's happened to Tom Huddleston there
wasn't it's all about touring apparentiy
all the money's in touring and you're
sending down though the new pound coin
it is far outside it and I don't know
what a 12 sided coin is but it reminds
me of course how do you spell it good
DoD quiz at all it is not the old
thrupenny bit and of course vending
machines can't cope with it so
everything's going to be change why do
they do come on you only have paper
money you never have any good talking to
a fat you I'm worried about supermarket
trolleys when you put it in and get your
trolley has been off his trolley few
years why doesn't someone tweeted this
week given the value of sterling isn't
it ironic that it's shaped a bit like a
fifty P because that's all of your worth
by next March so so we're sending it
down the pound coin has gone down thank
you both very much thank you
and do send us your nominations if you
want to send something up or down or
indeed the gaff the week using the
hashtag W in our well thank you at home
for joining us for our review of the
week we'll be back with much more next
week but for now it's goodbye from then
goodbye and it's goodbye from me goodbye
you